je vous le disais en titre c'est
finalement le beauceron de la mer qui a
eu le dernier mot francis joyon le natif
de ans en eure-et-loir a remporté la 11e
édition de la route du rhum à la barre
de son trimaran idec sport il a dépassé
françois gabart de seulement 7 minutes
sur la ligne d'arrivée est les images de
ce final haletant avec le commentaire
d'alain aide
il a enfin déboucher la bouteille croyez
au vainqueur de la route du rhum après
cette participation et beaucoup de
déboires
francis joyon a déjoué les pronostics
son bateau était 17 ans trop vieux lui
même l'ancien de la flotte à 62 ans
peut-être plus assez résistant pour
cette course éprouvante au bout d'un
sprint de plus de 6500 km joyon a
finalement donné la leçon à tous
décrochant à la fois la victoire et le
record de l'épreuve en sept jours 14h21
et 47 secondes
c'est vrai que quand on a une victoire
après avoir passé
de nombreuses éditions on la savoure
d'autant plus j'avais l'impression de
réciter un petit peu l'arrivée peut me
dire ce que j'ai pour qui j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration en 1978 mike birch avait
battu michal malinowski de 98 secondes
cette fois francis joyon gagne avec 7
minutes d'avancé sur le grand trimaran
massif de françois gabart
comme il ya 40 ans tout s'est joué lors
du contournement de la guadeloupe où
l'absence de vent a imposé aux deux
skippers une régate au suspense
étouffant françois gabart a perdu son
duel dans les ultimes hectomètres du
parcours et a tout de suite salué la
performance de son adversaire
parce qu'avec francis était super et que
j'ai vécu des émotions de tous niveaux
jusqu'au bout et encore la même jusqu'à
maintenant qu'ils sont probablement
aussi forte que s'il avait gagné les
deux hommes se sont immédiatement
congratuler après ce finish
époustouflant
mais c'est bien francis joyon le
beauceron de la mer qui entrent dans la
légende de la course au lin et le héros
du jour francis joyon est donc notre
invité en direct de pointe à pitre en
guadeloupe
bonsoir francis joyon merci d'être avec
nous félicitations à vous c'est une
victoire avec un scénario incroyable et
ce que vous l'imaginiez ce final a gagné
la route du rhum dans les tout derniers
instants
c'est vrai que c'était tellement
haletant et extraordinaire d'être au
contact comme ça sur le tour de la
guadeloupe et encore plus sur les
derniers mètres avant la ligne un
joaillier dans le noir le bateau de
françois qui était avec ses énormes
voile juste à côté de moi qui allait
plus vite sous le vent et c'était
vraiment très très fort de sentir cette
énorme présence après ces journées de
solitude hall au grand large
c'est extrêmement rare ce type de
victoire on la dit il n'y a eu qu'un
seul précédent il ya 40 ans lors de la
première édition de la route du rhum
vous y avez pensé évidemment ben oui
bien sûr j'ai pensé à cette arrivée
anthologique avec mike birch oui oui
c'est l'arrivée de la première route du
rhum et c'est ce qui a fait un petit peu
le l'histoire de cette course et le
renom de cette course me fait qu'il y
ait aussi à un petit multicoque qui
arrivent plus vite qu'un grand monaco
bon bah on était deux grands multicoques
les questions seront ce prix tellement
maintenant entre les différences de
vitesse d'un bateau à l'autre alors
rester encore un peu avec nous francis
joyon va aller à drew sur drew est le
village d'eure-et-loir où vous avez
grandi avec votre famille et il n'y a
pas la mer et pourtant c'est bien là que
vous avez appris la navigation c'est ce
que nous raconte garraud kevorkian et
étienne breil on a stressé j'ai stressé
jusqu'au bout
difficile d'aller se coucher quand votre
fils réalise l'une des plus belles
courses de sa carrière
claudine la mère de francis joyon est
resté éveillé toute la nuit pour suivre
la victoire de son grand garçon
je savais qu'ils pouvaient le faire
parce qu'il est très tacticien au niveau
wad loupe
il connaît bien l'arrivée en guadeloupe
mais vu les possibilités du bateau de
gabarre attention c'est un super bateau
et puis avec apparat super navigateurs
aussi v et qu'on s'est vus je dépassais
été olalalala bon dieu pour lui qui
garde la distance
si francis joyon c'est destiné au grand
large suit un stage de voile à 17 ans
c'est dès son plus jeune âge que l'
envie d'aller sur l'eau lui est venue il
avait un petit copain
il y avait une vieille baignoire qui
servait plus à rien alors qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait les gamins ils ont eu la
mémoire sur la brouette et ils ont
navigué pensons arriver peut-être à la
scène sa voix était bien loire je t'ai
jamais montrer tout ça mais en fait moi
je garde tout tout tout depuis qu'il a
commencé cette victoire avec panache
fait aussi la fierté de sa cousine
une fervente supportrice qui suit toute
la carrière de l'homme de tous les
records
et pour elle cette nouvelle victoire est
sans doute la plus belle car la plus
difficile et le corps en pâture agréable
c'est incroyable quoi surtout avec les
conditions épouvantables qu'ils ont eue
quand vous avez un navigateur qui
s'arrête en disant moi je vais pas plus
loin
j'ai peur avec cette victoire
francis joyon prend enfin sa revanche
sur cette course lui qui avait chaviré à
deux reprises alors francis joyon qu'est
ce que ça vous fait d'entendre la
réaction de vos proches en eure et loir
non je n'ai pas c'est vrai que j'ai pas
le temps de téléphoner un moment depuis
mon arrivée tellement la vie a été
agitée déjà profi te le dire un petit
bonjour on se parle parle de la
interposés c'est original ses
originalités de fière de ce qu'elle a
dit c'est vrai que ben c'est beaucoup
c'est grâce à un petit peu à ce stage de
voile qu'elle a à gentiment offert que
j'ai pu découvrir la voile est avancé
après dans la voile et c'est vrai cette
anecdote vous avez appris à naviguer
dans une baignoire sur la droite n'était
pas n'importe quel baignoire c'était on
avait mis des planches à travers on a
une idée bidon amarré sur les côtés en
fait c'était en été ont réinventé le
prix marrant on savait pas que ça
existait et avec les copains on
s'aventurait comme ça on avait des
problèmes de bras de liaison et enfin
des problèmes structurels classique
qu'ont connu mes concurrents je les ai
connus dans la drôme est déjà
sûr qu'on la droite ça fait un mètre
soixante dix de large c'est pas une
aventure raisonnable c'est une fierté
pour vous francis joyon d'être
originaire de la beauce plutôt que de la
bretagne comme beaucoup d'autres
navigateurs
ben c'est vrai que c'est là que je suis
n'est donc je ne le renie pas c'est là
où ou moment habite encore et c'est vrai
que là il n'y a pas que les grands
champs de blé a d'ailleurs j'ai vu que
les grands champs de blé se hérisser
d'éoliennes et je trouve que c'est une
très bonne idée d'utiliser les énergies
naturelles
ça donne une grandeur aux paysages que
que j'ai beaucoup apprécié moi qui ai
une fibre écologique développés qui aime
pas trop les centrales nucléaires j'ai
trouvé très beau c'est central très très
beau ces éoliennes qui surgissait dans
la beauce une dernière question
rapidement enfoncé joyon vous avez 62
ans vous êtes loin encore de la retraite
est ce que vous comptez repartir pour un
nouveau tour du monde
alors bon on n'a pas pris de décision
j'attendais un peu de voir le résultat
de cette route du rhum c'est l'orgie
j'étais encore à peu près à peu près
performants donc du coup je pense qu'on
va repartir encore sur une saison
ça fait 16 ans qu'on a vite comme ça
avec des condiments gracieux
si ça marche bien que moi je suis
content et aussi on continue mais
finalement à chaque fois ça se passe
bien donc on continue
voilà merci beaucoup francis joyon
d'avoir été notre invité depuis
pointe-à-pitre en guadeloupe où vous
avez remporté donc et cette route du
rhum avec panache félicitations encore
pour votre belle victoire